once again sandy alcatra 27th start of
the year back-to-back outings against
the reds and uh listen he has been great
from alcantara to naiquin
there we go
he got him
turns on a hundred and shoots it past
rojas well that's the bat speed of
castellanos holds that one 5-6 hole for
a two-out single those two did not pitch
in that four-game set sandy gets the
strikeout of joey votto
and he gets a couple of k's in the first
inning now the reds have two faces that
have long been viewed as front-runners
for rookie of the year but ad vladimir
gutierrez it's a long look in for
gutierrez here comes a 2-2 pitch
and it's hit past mustaches and into
left field to base it for rojas
barnhart sets up away again on 3-1
and jazz goes with it into left field to
base it
so the marlins have two on and nobody
out a nice approach the 3-0 pitch was
off that outside edge that has jazz
thinking off that outside edge paul's
great question last night we talked
about jazz and his willingness to go to
the opposite field when he knows knows
there's only one defender over there
tonight he's willing to go over that way
they've got alfaro coming to the plate
the base is loaded and nobody out 002
and alfaro pokes one into right field
there's a base hit jazz is coming around
castellanos throw is cut off aguilar
goes to third
and he is out but it's a two rbi single
for jorge alfaro and now marlins jump
out to a two to nothing lead
2-2 now
is to third mustache gets to it from
foul territory throw goes to first it's
late alfaro moves to third in field
single for brian anderson and the
marlins have him on the quarters well
still not done only one outrunners on
the corners and it's jesus sanchez
and sanchez tattoos one
way out of here three-run home run for
azu sanchez
now that's how you celebrate dominican
heritage night
first pitch
long gone
shot right by the diving shortstop as
rojas took a couple of steps towards
third base dove and schrock that missile
goes into left field for a base in
that one seemed to stun it but it gets
the job done
that was more of a self-preservation
i'm gonna i'm bunning this ball so it
doesn't hit me in the face
check this out
hey i got it
and there's his first hit in his
homecoming
stop sign for schrock alfaro fires in
in diazone with a hard single
naked win to center field that is deep
skips off the wall
schrock scores stop sign for india rbi
double for naked fire to third india
able to get back in he goes down
clutching at his right cleat
and the reds on the board it's five to
one
and he got him to chase the slider
strikeout number four for sandy and it's
out number two 235 hitter he's hit five
home runs including tonight moderate
lead runner doesn't go shot by sanchez
gloved by india what a nice diving play
by the red second baseman
took one step to his right dove and
there was the baseball in his glove
gave up a run and the base is loaded
picked up the strikeout to get out of
that inning limit the damage andy makes
the play at third spins and throws fires
a strike to angular
and farmer is retired
anderson over the last couple of weeks
has been on fire defensively i mean he
really has just about anything
to the left side he is gobbling up
last step able to get to the ball in a
good strong throw
sandy alcatra goes back to work reds
have been threatening but
sandy's been able to buckle down as he
gets naked for a second time tonight
eight strikeouts reinvented himself a
number of times in this start tonight
did it again goes to it again strikes
out bottom
nine strikeouts for sandy alcantara
to bring up brian de la cruz base hit
back in the first inning
de la cruz based it up in the middle
another multi-hit game for him
andy stops at second de la cruz
with two more hits jackson walks faces
are loaded for sandy
strike three called
and now bases loaded miguel rojas who
has singled and scored he's one for
three
ground ball to india
takes one pitch the lead off man
a race the deficit still sits at four
two outs nobody on a one-two pitch to
barnhart swing in the miss he struck him
out sandia contra with another 10k game
and how about tucker barnhart breaking
his bat over his knee in frustration as
the reds go one two three in the sixth
sandy cruising along with a 5-1 lead
jazz lines one to right castellanos will
play this one off the wall
extra bases for jazz
in the second with a lead off double
well jazz is having himself quite the
ball game tonight marlins got on the
board in the first inning they scored
five but the first two were thanks to
jorge alfaro he bats with jazz at second
and one out here in the bottom of the
sixth inning
alfaro
left center
and that's gonna go one up on the wall
here comes jazz
and alfaro's got himself an rbi double
fourth time this year he struck out
double digits
and now he matches
his career high with 11 strikeouts in
back-to-back outings both against the
reds
1-2
and another new career high for sandy
alcatra
set it in his last start and he resets
it tonight with a dozen k's
how about the night for sandy looking
for that final out here at lone depot
payoff pitch from detweiler
is a cold strike three
it's a marlins win
they get five in the first inning and
sandy alcatra does the rest
sets a new career high in strikeouts
with 12
and does so on dominican heritage night
he was brilliant as the marlins finally
pick up a win against the red